this video was made possible by
skillshare learn new skills for free for
a month by being one of the first 1000
to head to the link in the description
the story of saudi arabia's oil problem
starts with success
almost a century ago after three decades
of bloody complex conquest over
belligerence as small as tribes and as
large as the ottoman empire abdulaziz
bin abdullah rahman al-saad finally held
nearly all of the arabian peninsulas
territory his military and political
triumph was rewarded with his ability on
september 23 1932 to unify his dominions
into a single modern arab state
the kingdom of saudi arabia
that was hardly the end of his success
though with new-found tenuous stability
across the peninsula abdulaziz started
work to verify a long-held hunch he
believed without any real evidence that
there must be oil in arabia
this was typically brushed aside by oil
companies as the starry-eyed fantasies
of a desperate ruler of an inhospitable
land but he was of course correct in
1932 neighboring bahrain struck oil and
suddenly the king's fantasies weren't so
fanciful after all on march 3rd 1938
standard oil of california struck oil at
saudi arabia's daman number 7 drill site
successful oil exploration was followed
up by more exploration which too was
successful and as more and more wells
punctuated the arabian peninsula the
success only compounded
as it turned out this bearing dusty
peninsula was home to the single largest
proven oil field on earth
this was good for abdulaziz he grew rich
his country developed his kingship was
solidified in a mere decade he went from
leading some lowly nomadic tribes in an
uncharted land to striking diplomatic
deals with the president of the united
states
prosperity reigned over the coming
decades as power was passed from abdul
aziz to his son then to another of his
sons and so on and so forth in an era
defined by unprecedented success there
was little reason for the people to push
back on a now antiquated form of
governance a social contract started to
emerge the people would support the
monarchy politically if the monarchy
supported the people financially
infrastructure subsidies handouts
housing the monarchy provided all
saudi arabia's fortunes only improved as
the start of the 21st century ushered in
a historical rise in oil prices the
country's gdp nearly tripled in just
eight years and riyadh was inundated by
high-end hotels foreign faces and
international consulting firms the money
and fortune seemed endless and
effortless
until
of course
it ended
crude oil traded at an all-time high of
147.26
in july 2008. over the coming months as
the world descended into its deepest
financial crisis since the great
depression prices steadily slid down to
just
dollars a barrel and nearly four-fold
collapse in half a year
the direct impacts of this crash on
saudi arabia were surprisingly minimal
as the government had amassed vast
financial reserves over the prior
decades of prosperity and oil prices
quickly started ticking up again ending
2009 at around 80 dollars a barrel a
figure the kingdom could live with but
then it happened again in summer 2014
prices began a steady slide that would
bottom out at 33 a barrel in january
2016
a symptom of incredible global
oversupply between 2016 and 2020 prices
would average about 51.20
the problem however was this number over
the same period the breakeven oil price
the average price at which the country's
oil industry as a whole turns a profit
was 85
and 70 cents
this isn't to say that saudi oil
companies simply couldn't turn a profit
but it does mean that there were fewer
opportunities to turn a profit there
were fewer wells whose operating costs
were low enough to enable profitable
operations with an oil sector
representing close to half of gdp saudi
arabia had to dip into its financial
reserves which therefore began a
precipitous decline in a country defined
by its social compact financial support
by the monarchy in exchange for
political support by the people
seismic changes occurred starting on
january 1st 2018 for the first time ever
the saudi people were asked to help fund
the government
on any purchase of goods and services
they would now pay a five percent
value added tax
some of the risks of running such a
deeply oil entrenched economy are
straightforward for example we know that
sometime in the future a day will occur
that will come to be known as peak oil
experts agree that either demand decline
supply constraints or mix of both will
lead to the world's oil production
reaching a plateau before a decline
now past predictions on the timing of
such an event have overwhelmingly proved
inaccurate most experts in the 70s
expected production to level off by 2000
but there are now stronger indications
that peak oil is nearing between 2018
and 2019 oil production ticked down
slightly
this wasn't the first year-to-year
production drop in the 2000s but both
other instances 2002 and 2009 can be
directly attributed to major external
crises 911 and the great recession in
2019 production dropped simply because
of market factors
of course then in 2020 another external
crisis occurred which led to the
steepest year-to-year decline in recent
history but the pandemic might lead to
structural long-term changes such as
less driving with more people working
from home that would result in a
permanent drop in demand
so now
whether oil production will fully
recover and start growing again is in
legitimate question and some answers
have started to emerge
shell one of the world's largest oil
producers has said that it believes 2019
was its high water mark for production
peak oil might have already occurred
that is undoubtedly bad for saudi arabia
but potentially less devastating than
one might think at least in the near
term
located on some of the most accessible
oil fuels in the world saudi wells boast
some of the world's cheapest production
costs meaning they will not be the first
to close down once demand declines
however it's still the case that going
forward is going to be harder to base an
economy on oil than before
looking at the graph of crude oil prices
since 1983 the era before 2005 is
noticeably different than that after
it's not the prices themselves that
matter here it's the fluctuations
oil prices have never before been this
volatile these semi-regular four-fold
spikes or drops that occur in mere
months are a new phenomenon
running an economy on such a volatile
commodity is incredibly difficult and
this price volatility is only expected
to increase in the future as industry
disruption ramps up
simply put
running an economy on oil in the 21st
century is not a good idea
some in saudi arabia know this
of king abdulaziz's 45 sons 36 survived
to adulthood and six ascended to the
throne upon the death of his
half-brother in 2015 king salman bin
abdulaziz became the latest to rule the
kingdom already aged 79 and with
brothers only marginally younger the
decision was made that salman would be
the last of his generation to rule and
so muhammad bin naif a grandson of king
abdulaziz was appointed crown prince
next in line for the throne
meanwhile muhammad bin salman would
serve as deputy crown prince
two years later however shortly before
midnight on june 20th muhammad bin naif
was summoned to the safa palace in mecca
for a meeting with the king that meeting
did not materialize however as he was
led into another room held captive and
told by royal court officials that he
must give up his claim to the throne
after hours locked in that room muhammad
bin naif agreed to resign
the deputy crown prince and son of the
king mohammed bin salman was now next in
line for the throne over the years prior
the 31 year old had quietly worked to
amass power in the background and
increasingly became the face of the
saudi royal family reports indicate that
he was indeed responsible for
orchestrating the former crown prince
ousting which is not a stretch to
believe in fact he has gained so much
influence over his father's decision
making that he is now considered nearly
universally the de facto ruler of saudi
arabia
mohammed bin salman recognized his
country's oil problem before his ascent
however in late 2015 the mckinsey global
institute published a detailed 144-page
report analyzing the future prospects of
saudi arabia's economy in the wake of
2014's oil price crash this issued some
dire predictions
their base case what they expected would
happen without any major proactive
changes by saudi arabia predicted that
between 2014 and 2030 the country's
average monthly household income would
fall from 3 800 to 3 000 the
unemployment rate would rise from 12 to
22 percent and 900 billion dollars in
government assets would be replaced by
two trillion dollars in debt in short
saudi arabia was on the path towards
fiscal collapse
this attracted attention most
importantly that
of muhammad bin salman marking the first
major move on his rise towards de facto
ruler mbs took on the country's biggest
challenge ever
he fulfilled his reputation as a
reformer and plotted a path to transform
saudi arabia it was called vision 2030.
according to this plan transforming
saudi arabia into a sustainable nation
involved three primary objectives
improve the government the economy and
society
that first pillar government was perhaps
the broadest in scope ranging between
decreasing corruption stripping down
bureaucracy moving government services
online and far more perhaps the most
dramatic manifestation of this mission
occurred mere months after mbs's
promotion to crown prince when some 500
government ministers business people and
royal family members were rounded up and
detained in the ritz-carlton hotel in
riyadh until they could stand trial for
corruption the degree to which this
crackdown was legitimate is up for
debate but it did net the government a
hefty 170 billion dollars in assets in
the ensuing settlement deals the second
pillar related to economic reform was
also composed of a broad collection of
initiatives including privatizing
certain government services increasing
participation among women in the
workforce attracting increased
investment in the country by foreign
companies recharging government coffers
and growing private sector industries in
addition in a country known for its
prohibition of all but religious
tourists saudi arabia would now allow
and embrace foreign visitors taking a
page from the uae's economic
diversification playbook of course to
make tourism work one needs a place that
tourists want to go and that's a key
focus of the third and final pillar
improving society
now saudi society has long been defined
by a strict interpretation of islamic
principles shops briefly close for each
of five daily prayers religious police
roam the street enforcing strict dress
codes homosexual activity is punishable
by execution adult women are required to
have a legal guardian to make decisions
on their behalf atheists are legally
defined as terrorists and plenty more in
some saudi society was not one that many
foreign tourists would feel comfortable
visiting and beyond that considering
their interpretation of islamic
principles prohibited it there was
little of what most foreign tourists
would consider entertainment therefore
mbs went on a mission to change that the
country reversed a 30-year ban on movie
theaters and partnered with amc to open
dozens of cinemas across the country it
established the region's largest music
festival with artists like david guetta
steve aoki and tiesto getting to deal
with six flags to open a theme park in
the country and it gained a coveted spot
on 2021's formula one calendar with the
first ever saudi arabian grand prix in
addition some of their most regressive
social policies were abolished women
were now allowed to drive leave the
country without their guardian's
permission watch live sports and wear a
wider variety of clothing types
altogether saudi arabia increasingly on
the surface was starting to look more
like its neighbors bahrain qatar and the
uae countries socially and politically
rooted in islam but open to elements of
the increasingly globalized western
lifestyle below the surface however
it soon became clear that far less had
changed
on october 2nd 2018 shortly after 1pm
journalist and saudi dissident jamal
khashoggi entered the consulate of saudi
arabia in istanbul turkey to seek
necessary documentation for his upcoming
marriage he was never seen again
in the days weeks and months that
followed it emerged that khashoggi had
been assassinated seemingly in
retribution for critical coverage of the
saudi government and according to the
cia and other intelligence organizations
the killing was ordered directly by
muhammad
bin salman
while stifling descent was nothing new
for saudi arabia the assassination of a
journalist for a western paper on
foreign soil struck a chord with
international observers that elicited a
level of outrage unfamiliar for saudi
arabia the country was used to
condemnations by amnesty international
critical statements by ministries of
foreign affairs and world news section
stories about their various human rights
abuses but never before had the
country's misconduct reached front page
status globally never before had an
instance of saudi cruelty permeated into
common knowledge
backed up by less covered incidents such
as saudi arabia's alleged war crimes in
yemen the hacking of jeff bezos's phone
who owns the washington post where
khashoggi's columns were published and
continued stifling of dissent an
informal international consensus was
formed
despite the more liberal laws the theme
parks the music festivals and more deep
down saudi arabia was not reformed
and now the world knew it
this is an issue for saudi arabia
now when david guetta performs in saudi
arabia he has to deal with a barrage of
critical articles when formula one
announces its upcoming saudi arabia
grand prix it is faced with memes liking
it to racing in pyongyang or kabul when
amc continues with its planned expansion
into the country it encounters
reputational damage when his competitor
pulls out on ethical grounds this all
has a cost
if a business faces similar profit
opportunity in both saudi arabia and say
the uae they're going to pick the uae as
it's been far more successful at
building a friendly face for the west
despite an also iffy record on human
rights
altogether
these and other factors have meant that
vision 2030 is still but a vision
the plan laid out four key performance
indicators to track the highest level
goals of the project the first was the
percentage of the country's gross
domestic product attributable to the
private sector rather than state-owned
enterprises like saudi aramco
considering the private sector involves
non-oil industries growing it is key to
diversification
in 2016 this percentage stood at 40
percent and the goal was for it to reach
65 by 2030. today over the past four
financial quarters that number stands at
42.7
a crucial aspect of growing non-oil
revenues involves attracting foreign
direct investments they want for example
an investor from singapore to decide to
open a hilton at the new six flags theme
park foreign investment is key to
kickstarting natural compounding private
sector economic growth in 2016 foreign
direct investment represented 3.8 of the
country's gdp at least according to the
saudi government and the goal was for it
to grow to 5.7 by 2030. today according
to the world bank foreign direct
investment represents only 0.57
of gdp the next indicator non-oil
exports as a percentage of overall
exports is perhaps the only glimmer of
hope with a 2016 baseline of 16 and a
goal of 50 by 2030
22.4 percent of the country's exports
are now non-oil products
this is however well below the pace of
growth needed to reach the goal
finally the unemployment rate of saudi
nationals stood at 11.6 in 2016 and
despite the goal of bringing it down to
7 by 2030 it has since ticked up
slightly to 11.7
all around the vision of 2030 is not
being realized
now of course there's been an
unprecedented pandemic of course oil
prices have been low and of course these
are only the first years of reform but
all that notwithstanding there's little
evidence of deviation from the current
failing path a huge chunk of the
government's money is being sunk into
mega development projects like a 500
billion planned smart city along the red
sea or a three billion dollar
entertainment district near riyadh to
play host to the six flags formula one
track and more but mega projects like
this
don't work in the united arab emirates
flashy developments like the burj
khalifa and the palm islands weren't
what transformed the country into the
most diversified economy in the region
it was the unglamorous boring task of
crafting a business environment that the
world feels they can cooperate with
businesses want access to saudi arabia
because it's a massive untapped market
but right now it's just too risky an
environment for them it's too risky to
operate in an absolute monarchy with a
track record of volatile infighting it's
too risky to operate in a country known
for eye-catching human rights abuses at
home and abroad it's too risky to
operate in a country where women in the
workplace have fewer rights than their
male counterparts it's too risky to
operate in a country whose legal system
is based on a strict yet ambiguous
interpretation of sharia law
saudi arabia has the riches to brute
force some private sector growth it has
the money to lure some international
investment but as of yet it does not
have the vision to kick-start organic
economic transformation reform so far
has been superficial but those making
the decisions that matter to saudi
arabia can see through that
therefore
if saudi arabia actually wants to cement
its place in 2030's world it's going to
have to engage in what its leaders want
least
radical
fundamental
systematic change
as the story of saudi arabia proves so
well diversification is crucial and this
doesn't only apply to massive world
economies but also to you
being someone who can do one thing well
is great but being someone who can do a
wide variety of things makes you
uniquely valuable and irreplaceable
that's why i find skillshare so useful
they're an online learning community
with thousands of well-produced classes
taught by the actual practitioners of a
given skill for example one really
useful skill applicable to almost any
job and even school is graphic design it
can help spruce up your reports
powerpoints websites and really any
other visual project skillshare's class
on graphic design basics is taunted by
ellen lupton curator of the
smithsonian's design museum in new york
and in just 36 minutes you'll pick up
principles that you'll use for the rest
of your life
whether you want to learn web
development painting music production
video editing or really any skill
skillshare is the place to go and you
can start improving yourself for free
for a month by being one of the first
1000 to click on this button or head to
the link in the description signing up
helps support wendover and your own
skill development so head to skillshare
today